♪
>> Bret: PRESIDENT BIDEN SAYS HE
IS CONSIDERING ALLOWING TROOPS
TO HELP BRING U.S. CITIZENS
THROUGHOUT KABUL TO THE AIRPORT
TO GET THEM THEIR SAFELY.
BRITAIN AND FRANCE AS WE HAVE
REPORTED, HAVE ALREADY SENT
SPECIAL FORCES TO ASSIST THEIR
CITIZENS AND ALLIES INRMISSION T
IN KABUL AND CARRY OUT RESCUE
OPERATIONS EVEN THOUGH BRITISH,
FRENCH AND GERMAN PARATROOPERS
ARE DOING SO.
ONE BRAVE AMERICAN UNIT DID
RESCUE 169 AMERICANS STUCK JUST
OUTSIDE THE AIRPORT AT A TALIBAN
CHECK POINT.
WE HAVE ALSO LEARNED THAT A
MARINE FROM THE 24TH MARINE
EXPEDITIONARY GROUP LIFTED THIS
AFGHAN BABY TO SAFETY DELIVERING
THE CHILD TO MEDICAL PERSONNEL.
THE BABY WAS REUNITED WITH HIS
FATHER.
NEW DETAILS ARE ALSO EMERGING
ABOUT THIS EVACUATION FLIGHT
FROM SUNDAY.
823 AFGHANS NOT 640 WERE
SQUEEZED ON TO THIS RESCUE
FLIGHT DUE TO THE QUICK THINKING
OF AIRMEN FIRST CLASS NICHOLAS
BARRON THE LOAD MASTER AND
LIEUTENANT COLONEL WHO FLEW THE
PLANE.
THEY SAID THERE WAS NO TIME TO
WORRY ABOUT SEAT BELTS.
>> WE DID WHAT NEEDED TO BE DONE
TO DELIVER HOPE AND FREEDOM.
WE KNEW THE ABILITY OF OUR
AIRCRAFT AND SAFELY AND
EFFECTIVELY WITH ALL THE CREW
MEMBERS I HAD HAD THE UPMOST
THEY WOULD GET IT DONE.
>> BIDEN SAYS U.SS INTO NATIONAL
INTEREST IN AFGHANISTAN.
>> LOOK, LET'S PUT THIS THING IN
PERSPECTIVE HERE.
WHAT INTEREST DO WE HAVE IN
AFGHANISTAN AT THIS POINT WITH
AL-QAEDA GONE?
>> WHAT IS YOUR CURRENT ESTIMATE
FOR HOW MANY AL-QAEDA ARE INSIDE
AFGHANISTAN?
>> I HAVEN'T SEEN AN ESTIMATE ON
THAT -- OKAY, I DON'T KNOW IF WE
HAVE AN EXACT ESTIMATE.
>> MILITARY INTELLIGENCE
ESTIMATE ABOUT HOW MANY AL-QAEDA
REMAIN IN AFGHANISTAN?
>> WE KNOW THAT AL-QAEDA IS A
PRESENCE AS WELL AS ISIS IN
AFGHANISTAN AND WE HAVE TALKED
ABOUT THAT FOR QUITE SOME TIME.
WE DO NOT BELIEVE IT IS
EXORBITANTLY HIGH BUT WE DON'T
HAVE AN EXACT FIGURE FOR YOU.
>> CAN YOU EXPLAIN WHY THERE IS
NO NATIONAL INTEREST IN
AFGHANISTAN?
WHY DID WE HAVE TROOPS THERE FOR
20 YEARS IF THERE IS NO NATIONAL
INTEREST IN AFGHANISTAN.
>> WE HAD A SIGNIFICANT INTEREST
IN BEING IN AFGHANISTAN TO OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY 20 YEARS AGO.
>> AND, BRET, WE HAVE JUST
LEARNED NEW DETAILS AFTER BEING
TOLD ALL DAY THAT U.S. TROOPS
WERE NOT LEAVING THE AIRPORT.
DID NOT HAVE PERMISSION TO GO
AND RESCUE AMERICANS INSIDE
KABUL OR OUTSIDE OF KABUL.
WE HAVE JUST LEARNED FROM THE
PENTAGON PRESS SECRETARY THAT
THREE CHINOOK HELICOPTERS
CARRIED OUT A RESCUE MISSION
ABOUT 200 YARDS FROM THE AIRPORT
WHERE 169 AMERICANS WERE
STRANDED AT A BUILDING.
THEY RESCUED THOSE 169 AMERICANS
AND BROUGHT THEM INTO THE
AIRPORT.
THEY ARE NOW SAFE.
BACK TO YOU.
>> Bret: JEN, QUICKLY, YOU KNOW,
WE SAW DEFENSE SECRETARY AUSTIN,
I GUESS, WEDNESDAY SAY WE DON'T
HAVE THE CAPABILITY TO GO OUT
AND COLLECT UP LARGE NUMBERS OF
PEOPLE.
IS IT POSSIBLE THAT IT MAY START
HAPPENING AND WE DON'T KNOW IT?
>> WELL, YOU ALWAYS HAVE A
POSSIBILITY OF MISSION CREEP ANY
TIME YOU HAVE U.S. FORCES ON THE
GROUND.
WHAT WE ARE SEEING IS THAT THERE
ARE CASES AND WHEN YOU HAVE
TROOPS THERE AND THERE ARE CALLS
FOR HELP, IT'S GOING TO BE
DIFFICULT FOR THEM T